i'm doing my best to lose weight i try
diet after diet and nothing works i'm
still fat do you feel like you tried
diet after diet and nothing works yeah
that's what i just said i've got just
the solution for you introducing the
all-new 2022 high inflation diet all the
luxuries you used to love like breakfast
fuel and heating are now off the table
that sounds yes the great thing about
the 2022 diet is you don't need to count
calories what because it doesn't contain
anything exactly does the diet actually
work then absolutely let's have a look
at a case study
another happy customer what about a full
meal francis you're letting your inner
fatty speak and i won't have it on the
no calorie high inflation diet the more
the pound loses value the more pounds
you lose and the best thing about this
diet is the way things are going there's
no stopping inflation making it
impossible to quit amazing are there any
other benefits of course as living costs
rise and then real wages full homes in
the uk will be forced to maintain a
constant temperature of three degrees
throughout winter why is that a positive
because you can save money on zumba
classes and just shiver your way to
fitness at home well britain is the
fastest nation in europe and i don't
want to lose our title it took us years
to win that thing and thanks to the
scots we've finally done it don't worry
about it the europeans are just as
screwed
[Music]